So yesterday Donald Trump unleashed a multi
tweet tirade against Fox News and we can now
say that Donald Trump has fully turned on
Fox News exactly as I predicted months ago.
First, I'll tell you what Donald Trump said
yesterday. Then we'll go back to how this
been building for awhile. Now, Donald Trump
is furious that Fox news even had Democrats
on their channel saying that there are a,
it's time to look for something else. And
also saying a lot of other bizarre and completely
just unintelligible things. So let's take
a look. Trump tweeting in a three tweet tweetstorm
yesterday quote, just watch Fox News heavily
promoting Democrats through their DNC communications
director, spewing, spewing out whatever she
wanted with zero pushback by anchor Sandra
Smith. Terrible considering that Fox couldn't
even land a debate. The Dems give them nothing.
CNN and MSNBC are all in for the open border
socialists or beyond. Fox hires give Hillary
the questions. Donna Brazil who won Williams
and low ratings, Shep Smith, hopeless and
clueless, they should all go the way that
they should all. They should go all the way
left and I will still find a way to win.
That's what I do when too bad. I don't want
to win for myself. I only want to win for
the people. The New Fox News is letting millions
of great people down. We have to start looking
for a news outlet. Fox isn't working for us
anymore. Um, so this has been building for
awhile. I've been talking about this, but
before I even get to that, it's so it, it
seems patronizing the language that Donald
Trump is using when he tries to explain to
people on Twitter that he wants to win for
them and that it's all for them. For most
people who have sort of like a, an understanding
of the real world, it's the most patronizing
and childish way or, or demeaning way for
a 73 year old president to be speaking to
the country. But clearly this is language
that actually does resonate with people. People
actually see Trump speak to them in this way
via Twitter or speeches or wherever else.
And it seems sincere to them and it seems
genuine and that, that, that's just a problem.
I think that is a bigger picture issue than
Trump even. Uh, but let's put that aside for
a second. This anti-fog stuff has slowly been
building for the last several months I've
been telling you about it. There's no fixed
relationship that's set in stone between Donald
Trump and Fox News. You might remember if
we think back to the beginning of the 2016
primary Fox News was not behind Donald Trump
at the beginning of the 2016 Republican primary.
They didn't take them seriously. They didn't
think he could win. They didn't support him.
Trump had some pretty public, uh, fights,
including with Megan Kelly and others on Fox
News. And Fox News was quite opposed to Donald
Trump and very publicly. So, and eventually,
I guess Trump, I'm going from memory, Trump's
sort of, um, uh, reconvened and made up with
Megan Kelly.
And Eventually Fox News sort of came around
to Donald Trump and has been quite frankly,
a pretty effective mouthpiece for Trump for
a long time. Trump co-opting fox news hosts
are Jeanine Pirro, Tucker Carlson, Sean Hannity,
developing personal relationships with these
people. Maria Bartiromo on Fox business and
other example. And it's been a pretty good,
a propaganda mouthpiece for Donald Trump for
a while now. But over the last year and a
half, sort of every once in awhile, a little
more over the last year, a little more over
the last six months, uh, every once in awhile.
Shep Smith or Chris Wallace or someone would
say something uncontroversially true about
Donald Trump that contradicted what Donald
Trump had said or the weekend anchors might
do coverage that Donald Trump doesn't like
or whatever, and slowly but surely Donald
Trump has been more and more angry with Fox
News because even Fox can't keep up the line
100% of the time. That's the truth. They can't
placate Trump all the time when all Donald
Trump does his lie and every once in a while
they have to tell the truth.
Now, I've also said that Trump, if he turns
on Fox News, may well start promoting the
even crazier network o a n one America News,
which if you watch it looks almost like a
porn parody of what a right wing news channel
would look like, but OAN is not joking. Oh,
AAN is for real. This is my clip talking about
this from a few months ago. Fox News is not
necessarily going to stick with Trump. They're
about profit and right-wing propaganda. In
a general sense, Trump might be the vehicle
for that propaganda, but he also might not.
And just to prepare you, if Trump and fox
have a falling out, you need to know that
Donald Trump's network of choice is going
to become this absolutely whacked out thing
called o a. N the one American use network
or one American use. Check it out online,
but not with kids in the room and not close
to meal times because it is truly, it'll,
it'll turn your stomach.
Uh, but o h n is where Trump will go if ultimately
he abandons Fox News as the propaganda vehicle
of choice. And then of course, about three
weeks ago, Donald Trump tweeting, watching
fake news, CNN is better than watching Shepard
Smith the lowest rated show on Fox News. Actually,
whenever possible, I turn to o a n n one America
News Network. So listen, um, yes, this was
written on the wall months ago and it does
seem to be happening. I've said before, we
are not going to win in 2020 because of a
primary challenge against Trump. We are not
going to win in 2020 because Donald Trump
gets impeached. We're not going to win in
2020 because Donald Trump turns on Fox News,
but every single one of those things could
hurt Trump slightly an impeachment inquiry
against Donald Trump. A would replace coverage
of Trump's campaign with coverage of the impeachment
inquiry that might damage Trump half a point
in a number of key states, a primary challenge
against Donald Trump, which he now has from
former Republican congressman Joe Walsh and
I guess still sort of from former Massachusetts
Governor William Weld, although you don't
really hear much about that, they're not going
to win the primary, but if they get a few
points of support from the 20% of Republicans
that don't approve of Trump, and then maybe
Joe Walsh decides to run as an independent
in 2020 maybe it'll siphon off a another half
point or one point or two points from Trump
in some key state.
It's not going to be the sole difference maker
that we can count on. And in the same way
if Donald Trump and fox news part fuck if
Fox remains conservative but not a pro Trump
110% of the time propaganda mouthpiece and
instead Donald Trump starts going to promote
OAN or whatever, which will have far lower
ratings. Maybe that also does just a sliver
of damage to Trump in some states where it
might might make a difference in the end.
If we combine all of these things with just
getting our base out, half the country doesn't
vote, let's just find people who agree with
us and explain to them the importance of voting.
All of that together may well lead to Donald
Trump's removal. That's my sense right now.
And so let's, you know, we, I did a stream
earlier this week, uh, with a, a former, a
Wall Street financier who now is like an independent
trader and the entire thing struck a lot of
people in the audience.
Like this is like very Wall Street center
right stuff. And I've been arguing for a long
time. We can simultaneously identify the problems
with the system, but also use the tools that
the system provides in the best way we can
to our advantage. And this is why I think
that even though there are so many structural
inequalities and problems with our financial
system, I still think it's important to be
informed about savings accounts, cds, mutual
funds, basic retirement planning and budgeting
and all of this stuff. Uh, because these are
tools that we can use to our advantage in
the exact same way. We need to think of the
tools that we have that we can use to our
advantage in 2020. I hate the status quo of
campaign finance, but it is the status quo
right now. And campaign advertising is something
that can be effective.
So Democrats should do it. The nicknames and
branding that Donald Trump is so successfully
used, it's childish and it's stupid, but it's
not violence. And it is effective if you read
the work of George Lake off. So Democrats
should take advantage and try to brand candidates,
including Donald Trump in a similar fashion
to how Donald Trump has branded democrats.
And in the exact same way, Trump's, uh, primary
challengers, all of these different things
we're talking about Trump's splitting with
Fox News. These can all be little tools that
we can try to foment a little bit just to
try to gain that advantage because in the
end it all can contribute to ultimately removing
Donald Trump. Make sure that you follow me
on that
Instagram at David Dot. Pacman. We will take
a quick break and be right back after this